jeanne mégantic les gens ne parlent et
j'ai toujours pensé aux jo richard
labrie a prononcé ces mots en janvier
2018 alors que lui et ses deux anciens
collègues de la compagnie ferroviaire
mma le conducteur du train home of
reading et le gestionnaire gens de m
venait d'être reconnus non coupables de
négligence criminelle causant la mort
des 47 victimes de la tragédie de lac
mégantic au terme de longues procédures
judiciaires pendant 44 mois cet apport
le char la mairie c'était un coaccusé de
la tragédie de mégantic
suite à cela la confiance à manger un
coup pour partir sa confiance ça sinon
des flashbacks de qu'est ce qui est
arrivé
pourquoi c'est arrivé presque sept ans
après les événements richard l'abri nous
accueille chez lui à saint jean sur le
richelieu
aujourd'hui je vais bien c'est sûr que
c'est une étape qui ont marqué ma vie
comme hier markit
beaucoup de vies ils acceptent de lire
la bande dessinées documentaires lac
mégantic la dernière nuit
même s'il n'est pas dessiner il est
présent du début à la fin du récit
cette nuit-là il est le contrôleur en
poste à farnham son rôle s'est dirigé au
téléphone les convois qui circulent sur
les rails de la mma je revis j'avais su
ce que vaut ce poste un peu avant une
heure du matin le convoi de soixante
douze wagons de pétrole brut stationner
sur la voie principale à nantes part à
la dérive
il file vers lac-mégantic accélère il ya
une heure quinze
le train déraille et explose tuant 47
personnes et détruisant le centre ville
[Musique]
le rappel de cette ruine enfin les
valeurs ont probablement parti n'a pas
défendu ses dix mois après le drame que
les policiers arrêtent richard l'abri
donc c'est elle est orga trois replis
tout le chou tout la bbl puis presque
l'intimidation 7h30 quand j'ai commencé
l'interrogatoire j'étais un bon gars
mais rentrent à minuit lors j'étais pas
bon être occupée pour hilla facile
d'être prêt si t'arrêtes face moi je dis
que moment de la tragédie
j'ai pris les meilleures décisions que
j'avais à prendre avec les informations
que j'avais la main bien essayé le
panier à salade jusqu'à mégantic menotté
les trous au top cette affaire et il
souffle et joie sortait le premier plan
n'attendaient que ça commence à crier
par l'effort quand j'ai débarqué moi
j'ai entendu juste une femme sur mon
côté gauche qui a dit c'est pas un homme
c'est pas de leur faute à nous on sait
pas autres comme lui j'ai su par
rappeler que cette femme-là avait perdu
sa fille
dans la très vite on a eu plus de sport
hockey des gens de mégantic qu'on en a
eu de nos confrères de travail qu'on en
a eu de la compagnie et mes mots qu'on
en ait eu de décès indique qu est ce que
le domaine ferroviaire vous manque
aujourd'hui
quant à lui arrêté après l'accident je
me suis dit ça va marquer 100 mais
terrible non seulement et puis de la
façon quand on a été traités par la
compagnie de sabine édile a beau vouloir
y retourner si on s'est fait poignarder
on s'est fait à bord d'année nous ont
jetés en pâture
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je travaille comme
journaliers un nettoyeur à saint jean
maintenant je marche la tête droite
quand ben dahmane mois puis je me serais
pas les yeux ici marie-hélène rousseau
radio canada saint jean sur le richelieu